te pregunto señor grajales si puede el
gobierno de un país en este caso el de
eeuu a obligar a sus empleados a tomar
una medicina una vacuna como recibe
usted estos anuncios del presidente de
bailén
bueno varias cosas primero que todo hay
que recordar que estamos hablando de
empleados federales en este aspecto pues
como si como si fueran en una empresa
privada en este caso el gobierno pues
tienen lineamientos y reglamentos con
sus empleados y tiene la postestad a
requerirle a los empleados algo que
consideran que es importante para el
desarrollo de su trabajo y para mantener
a los los trabajadores
pues saludables en este aspecto estamos
hablando más que de una medicina pues de
una vacuna que es algo preventivo lo
interesante de todo este tema es que yo
creo que ambos partidos han anunciado
muchísimo el tema de la vacuna el tema
de la pandemia y entonces se ha creado
esta situación donde hay un montón de
gente que no se quiere vacunar porque
tiene miedo y tiene dudas porque quizá
no entiende el proceso de la vacuna como
fue hecha pero hay varias cosas
importantes que resaltar muchas veces
tomamos medicinas o medicamentos o
vacunas que han usado un muestreo
muchísimo más menor del que ya hay en
este momento recordemos que
originalmente para que fuera aprobada la
vacuna como algo éste de emergencia fue
corto pero ahora ya hay más de hay
cientos de millones de personas
alrededor del mundo que ya se vacunaron
y deberían de tener este temor
ahora han cesar crearán estas medidas a
mayor división política y polarización
entre demócratas y republicanos que
tienen visiones muy distintas de la
importancia de la vacunación en este
caso contra kobe 19 rápidamente por
favor sí bueno yo creo que espero que no
pero obviamente reitero esto lo han
politizado a ambos lados de tristemente
el día de hoy por primera vez el
presidente reconoció que la
administración pasada encabezada por el
partido republicano son los que
desarrollaron la vacuna él mismo lo dijo
hoy y que ellos ahora en la
administración siendo control de
demócratas en la cámara y la cambia
casablanca son los que están
administrando estas vacunas yo creo que
ahorita lo importante es que la gente
entienda que es importante vacunarse